PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Welcome to "Get
Cooking in Cloud," where
we share the best recipes
to apply in your cloud kitchen.
I am Priyanka, and
in today's episode,
we'll share the recipe
to plan for data recovery
when production environment is
on premise or in another cloud.
Main Street Style is
an e-commerce company
that has their production
environment set up on premise.
Imagine if they were
to discover that they
have lost all the
recent customer
orders during a disaster.
It would be a huge
loss for their business
if orders are not fulfilled.
Since data is the critical
piece of their application,
let's dive deeper into it
and help Main Street Style
with some strategies to avoid
losing data during a disaster.
The term data covers two
scenarios, data backup
and database backups.
Backing up data alone involves
copying a discrete amount
of data from one
place to another
to recover from corruption
or when production's down.
Database backups,
on the other hand,
are slightly more complex,
because they typically involve
recovering to a point in time.
Hence, we need to
not just consider
backing up the
database, but also
consider backing up
the transaction logs
and then applying them back to
the database during recovery.
Now that we have the
basic understanding
of data and database
backups for DR,
let's consider Main
Street Style's scenario,
and how they can set up
DR specifically for data.
For data backup and recovery,
there are a few options.
They can create a
scheduled task that
runs a script or an
application to transfer
the data to cloud storage.
Or, they can automate
a backup process
to cloud storage using
gsutil command line,
or by using one of the cloud
storage client libraries.
The other option
for data recovery
is to use a third
party solution.
Main Street Style uses the most
common tiered storage pattern
where they have the most recent
backups on faster storage,
and slowly migrate the older
backups to a cheaper storage.
When they use Google
Cloud as their target,
they can use Cloud Storage
Nearline or Coldline
as the equivalents
of the slower tier.
One way to do this
is to use a partner
gateway between on-premise
storage and cloud storage.
Partner solutions
manage the transform
from an on-premise
network-attached storage
appliance or a
storage area network.
Now that we've learned about
data storage and recovery,
let's consider a database
backup and recovery.
Main Street Style can use
a number of strategies
to implement a process
to recover a database
system from on-premise
to Google Cloud.
Let's look at two of the
most common solutions.
They could do a backup and
recovery using a recovery
server on Google Cloud, or
they could use a standby server
on Google Cloud for application.
In the recovery
server approach, they
would create a
database backup using
the built-in backup mechanism of
the database management system.
This will typically create
the backup to a local disk.
Then, they would create
a Cloud Storage bucket
as a target for the data
backup in Google Cloud.
Copy the backup files
to Google Cloud Storage
using gsutil or a
partner gateway solution
that we looked at earlier.
Also, because this
is a database,
they would have to copy
the transaction logs
to the recovery site
on Google Cloud.
Having a backup of
the transaction logs
helps keep the RPO values small.
Then, they would
configure connectivity
to Google Cloud using
interconnect and VPN.
Create a custom image
of the database server
on Google Cloud with exactly the
same configurations as the one
on-premise.
Now, when time comes to recover
the database to the DR site
on Google Cloud, it's easy
for Main Street Style.
They would start a
minimally-sized instance
from the custom
image, and attach
any persistent disks needed.
Set the autodelete
flag to no autodelete
so that the persistent disk will
not be inadvertently deleted,
since that could be a disaster.
Then apply the latest
backup file and transaction
logs that we copied to
cloud storage, replace
the minimal instance with
the larger instance that's
capable of accepting
production traffic,
and finally, switch
the clients to point
to the recovered
database in Google Cloud.
When a production environment
on-premise is up and running,
they would just have
to reverse the steps.
Take a backup of the database
and transaction logs running
on Google Cloud, copy
these backup files
to the production
environment, and apply them
database system.
Prevent clients from
connecting to the database
system in Google Cloud by
stopping the database service.
From this point, the
application will be unavailable
until they finish restoring
the production environment.
And finally, redirect the client
connections to the production
environment, and that's it.
An alternative recipe is
to set up a standby server
on Google Cloud for application,
which helps achieve very
small RTO and RPO values
since it actually replicates
data and database
data in real time
to a hot standby of
the database server.
If Main Street Style was
just setup a standby server,
then here's how
they would do it.
They would first have to
connect their on-premise network
to the Google
Cloud network, then
create a custom image
of their database server
on Google Cloud in
the same configuration
as the one on-premise.
Start an instance
from the custom image,
and attach any
persistent disks that
are needed with the
autodelete flag set to false.
Then configure replication
between the on-premise database
server and the target database
server in Google Cloud.
The clients are configured
in normal operation
to point to the database
server on-premise.
After configuring this
replication topology,
they would have
to switch clients
to point to the standby
server running in Google Cloud
network.
When production database
on-premise is up and running,
they just resynchronize the
production database server
with the Google Cloud database
server and then switch clients
to point back to the
production environment.
Now, in our case,
Main Street Style
has production
setup on-premises.
But if they have the
production setup in AWS,
they can use the
storage transfer service
to transfer objects from
Amazon S3 to Cloud Storage.
They could set up a
transfer job to schedule
periodic synchronizations
from data source to the sync,
with advanced filters based on
file creation date, file name
filters, and the times of the
day you prefer to import data.
Or, they can also use
tools like Apache Airflow
to move data between clouds.
Well, there you have it.
If you have a production
application on-premise
or in another cloud and need to
set up the Data Recovery, then
hopefully, you've learned
some strategies to do that.
That's all for today on
"Get Cooking in Cloud."
Here's hoping you're whipping
up your own DR strategy.
Join us next time where
we will share more recipes
to implement DR for data.
If you would like to
see more such content,
don't forget to like and
subscribe to our channel.